foreign
[Music]
conference going for all of you
hopefully you can hear me good all set
for the LL Cool J and whatever the roots
all set for it awesome all right let's
have some fun so my name is Vijay tiwari
I'm on LinkedIn let's try and figure out
if I can get you to find me connect with
me and then I first posted the session
stuff go like it and try and get more
people to join in all right let's go so
my name is Vijay tawari last name is
tears and Tom he is in Edward W as in
Whiskey A is an apple r as in Roger I is
in India all right let's go
come on
let's see if we find folks
found me not yet
not exciting enough
I'm on X sorry Twitter two my handle is
V Tango in case you want to chat with me
there as well happy to sort of engage
with you there
and again the selfish interest after all
clearly you're interested in backup and
Disaster Recovery we represent the
backup and design Disaster Recovery team
so we want to continue this dialogue not
just about decision but beyond this as
well so that's part of the reason
all right let's see
somebody no yeah okay
two people
uh yeah awesome
that's great awesome
three awesome
let's keep going
so what's been the most exciting
announcement for you from next
besides the AI stuff
anyone
want to take a crack at it
come on there's been so much stuff that
we've announced or is it too much
anyone
sorry
oh kubernetes Enterprise that's awesome
that's great we've got a story for that
that's awesome that's great what else
alloy DB but alloy DB was GA before this
too
awesome that's great yep what else
what about sorry
I pick a pardon
oh do it okay that's that's AI okay
awesome
AI by definition is exciting so I'm
trying to find other exciting things
or else
sorry
of compute instances awesome that's
great yeah very cool feature what else
anybody else
all right now let's talk about AI what
about AI was exciting
come on let's go
do a terraform integration that's pretty
cool
so
um yeah that's good yeah we've been
experimenting obviously with barred
internally quite a bit and do it to
figure out uh how it is and you know
I'll tell you an example of
hallucination so way way back early we
started in the ask bar to tell us how do
you backup a a VM
and it spit out some beautifully
formatted text click on this button that
button problem was there was no such
button that existed so it took a little
while for us to sort of get the model
right and it's a work in progress but we
made a lot of you know sort of work gone
into sort of getting that air so and of
course it's a work in progress so use it
give feedback and continue down the path
it's one of those things that will only
improve if all of you use it
yeah
and then I discovered an awesome feature
yesterday
so Radha and a couple of us were at
dinner yesterday it turns out my watch
said that I was exercising on a bike
while I was having dinner that's the
kind of watch I want awesome
for 35 minutes it said I was having
rigorous exercise on my bike while
wearing dinner
you know
all right anybody else any last-minute
thoughts on what other thing was
exciting while you're here
but we really are grateful that you come
down to the conference it's really great
to be back together in in person we've
done this virtually over the last few
years
to be honest this is my first attendance
physically with with the next as well so
I joined Google in 2020
the the day Google shut down for remote
work or rather we were not allowed to
come into the office
so I have the dubious distinction of not
having gone through what is called as a
Google tech immersion in in Google
because they didn't know what to do with
us when we joined Google so I learned
through all the people who join in the
team
yes all right so that's great so lawyer
wanted to come on board let's get
started thank you so much really
appreciate
mm-hmm
hello Vijay thank you so much maybe I
should ask people to uh join my LinkedIn
so before we start welcome to Arc 200 I
want to get a sense of who's in the
audience I I see maybe some gke folks
over there who are excited about
Enterprise so first question who here is
responsible for security
oh that's a lot of people okay who here
is responsible for backup and Recovery
all right and who here is in devops
well this is a great representation of
so many different functions and the good
news is we're going to have content
that's relevant to all of you so stay
tuned you will get to hear from Vijay
soon
all right so let me introduce our folks
who are sitting over here so we have a
wonderful customer Dr Radu banabik who
comes to us from cyber Haven he's a
co-founder and VP of engineering of that
company now this is a very exciting
security company startup
and he'll tell you a little bit more
about this company but one of the things
that I found very interesting
is that they use data lineage to
identify suspicious activity
and in fact to do that they have
developed a trillion scale graph to look
at all the data moving throughout the
Enterprise so later on those in uh
security area can talk to Radu and ask
him their questions about his company
and Technology
now I'm Laura Finkelstein you can also
find me on LinkedIn I'm responsible for
outbound product management for the
backup area
Vijay tuari who you have already met is
the person responsible for all product
management for our data protection
products and you're also going to hear
from Radha mature who's within vijay's
organization who will show you some
demos later and she's responsible for
the Google Cloud backup and Dr product
so
I want to give you a map of what we're
going to be talking about today so you
know what's coming I'm going to talk to
you first about an overview of the it
challenges that you probably are facing
maybe not all of them but many of them
then I'm going to be turning it over to
Vijay who's going to go into a deeper
dive first on the Google Cloud portfolio
for backup as well as a specific product
called Google Cloud backup and Dr
then
Vijay is going to bring on to the stage
Rada who's going to talk to you about
show you how we defend against malicious
activities and just talk to you about
why backup is so essential for security
then Vijay again is going to Deep dive
into the backup for gke product again
something very interesting to the devops
folks here and Rod who is going to join
us on stage because he's a super user of
gke and backup for gke and he's going to
talk to you about how it's benefited his
company
and then finally we're going to just
summarize and give you a chance to ask
your questions so with that let's get
started
so you might have seen this slide here
if you went to the presentation that
Sachin Gupta gave earlier but really
what I wanted to point out is even
though you're coming from disparate
functions on top of that you have a
myriad of different workloads that
you're responsible for
and so this is kind of trying to capture
the Rai workloads there's traditional
workloads what we're going to talk about
today is security and availability for
those workloads
so I don't need to tell you that data is
the lifeblood of your organization and
that making sure that it's secure and
available is very difficult because
there's so many potential risks
that are there to take that data away or
make it unavailable
now what I wanted to mention is that
because Google also believes that
securing your data is so critical
Google has released in the last year two
new data protection products that you're
going to hear about in detail today
the first one Google Cloud backup and Dr
is a product that covers a large number
of workloads both on premises and within
the cloud
and then the other new product is a
product built specifically for gke that
deeply understands the nuances and
constructs of your gke clusters and
namespaces and it helps you to back that
up and recreate clusters exactly like
they were before
so let's talk about some of those
challenges
first and foremost many of you
particularly security folks are worried
about cyber attacks
now the problem here is that these
perpetrators
are going to be able to get in on any
surface so you can't defend across all
surfaces so inevitably they're going to
get in and so this is where backups come
in to be able to recover from this
problem
now the interesting one to me is I've
heard from numerous customers that their
biggest worry is user error the old fat
finger and so this is the problem that
you are most likely to bump into and
problematically you could be not only
losing your data but to potentially the
backups associated with that so we're
going to talk to you about how you can
defend against that as well
and another
non-malicious risk
is that you do a software upgrade or you
change your pipeline for your CI CD and
something breaks and so you really want
to immediately go back to the last known
state
this is really critical to keep your
productivity and your business
operations going
and then compliance the ability to
protect that data to keep it around as
long as you need to and to potentially
put it in the location you need to
because of other regulations
the last two that I want to mention is
yes occasionally Google goes down
and in those situations you're going to
want to have backups that are in a
different region so you can just bring
up your operations and continue in that
new region
and then finally there are some positive
aspects of backups that are not about
dealing with disasters and that is using
backups to really optimize your
operations to move the operations to a
better place for performance or cost
optimization as well as use your backup
data to develop your applications and
ensure that they're working before you
roll them out into production
oops am I going the wrong way here I am
here we go
so what you're going to hear from Vijay
and the team today
is really how do we address these issues
that we talked about on the previous
page
one of those approaches you're going to
hear about is how do I deal with
malicious attacks and two of the things
that we are delivering capability wise
within our backup products is first of
all immutable backups so no one can
modify encrypt
change corrupt those backups they are
there to be rolled back when you need
them
second and very importantly indelible
backups this means that no one can
delete them either externally or
internally it might be accidental as we
talked about from a user error or it
could be a bad internal perpetrator so
we will talk to you about how we prevent
when you don't want those backups being
deleted by anyone
the indelible backups
the other thing that we're going to talk
to you about is how these Google
products integrate with other Google
products
to allow you to look at unified logging
unified identity and access management
and the ability to really manage your
workloads and resources in a centralized
seamless way
and then finally you're going to hear as
we talked about earlier how you use
these products to improve your
operations that proactive approach and
so with that said I'm going to turn the
Baton over to Vijay who you've already
met and he's going to dive into that
thank you so much Laura really
appreciate it so first of all just to
you know I represent the work of over
100 Engineers so thank you so much for
attending and it's it's really great for
them to see the passion that you have in
the space so thank you so much for that
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
walk you through how Google thinks about
backup and Disaster Recovery right so
the couple of major things that we think
are fundamental to this which I think
Laura has already talked you through I'm
going to talk you to some of the core
capabilities that we have in the
platform which provides backup
functionality to you right
so this is a bit of a you know a big
chart but let me walk you through it
right so from a customer standpoint you
can interact with Google cloud in a
variety of different ways through the
API through the gcloud command line
interface through the user experience or
through other automation tools like
terraform right they layer on top of
what we call as Google apis all those
tools all those UI layer on top of
Google apis on the back end what we have
done is all the core services that we
have whether it is persistent disks
whether it is alloy DB whether it is gke
whether it is bigquery cloud SQL we are
working with all of those teams for
those teams to build core Primitives for
backup into those products right so if
you are a kind of a customer who doesn't
really need a finished backup and
Disaster Recovery product but acquired
comfortable of scripting your way and
sort of orchestrating backup across
these individual Resources by all means
we have a solution for you right that's
what represents the absolute right side
of this chart right you can orchestrate
in scripted GL you know command line it
whatever it is that's available for you
to use however you know that works for
some customers but then if
you're able to take and apply backup
policies across multiple different
elements that constitute your workloads
I've come across many customers
who are basically saying look I've got a
bunch of compute that's running in gke
I've got the back end infrastructure for
that application sitting in a cloud SQL
database and I want to be able to
consistently
in a back up policy which says I want
you to be able to back up the compute
and the database consistently at you
know take it daily
and retain it for seven days take it
weekly and retain that for 24 days and
take a monthly and retain that for a
year that's what Google Cloud backup and
Dr as a product is designed to do right
so it augments the functionality that
you get with the core Primitives but
layers on sophisticated capabilities on
top of that like reporting you know uh
sophisticated monitoring sophisticated
alerting
right a couple of things I want you to
think about when you think about Google
Cloud Backup backup and Dr so
during the session or maybe after the
session go log into the cloud console
and go look for backup and Dr it's
actually a product in Pantheon you'll
well not sorry Pantheon is the internal
code name for the UI the UI you'll
actually see the backup and Dr product
there and what it offers you there is
the ability to backup a robust set of
workloads that we support today so if
you're running on GCE VMS you're running
on gcve you're running sap Oracle MySQL
SQL Server we support backups for all
those workloads
mission is
Asics right you've got a VMware
infrastructure on premises
and you want to
that up into gcp you can retain like the
previous seven days of backup locally
but you actually want to back up you
know long term retention into gcp that's
another scenario that we support as well
right
the benefits that you could get with
Google Cloud backup and Dr is that it's
it's Google so that means all the
security benefits all the I am
compliance all the rbac integration you
get as a part of Google Cloud backup and
Dr right
um and obviously by virtue of being
Google Cloud backup and Dr it affords us
the opportunity to give you Google
tooling for what you get accustomed to
using when you're using Google so you
can walk up to the cloud monitoring
console in gcp and you'll be able to see
all the monitoring data from backups if
you want to be able to get an email
every Friday which says tell me all the
backups that fail during the week we can
do that and Cloud alerting can send this
communication across multiple different
communication channels right so that's
the benefit that you accrue from using
something like Google Cloud backup and
Dr Fair
so now that I've actually sort of given
you a high level view of how we think
about the core platform Primitives and
how Google Cloud backup and Dr actually
layers over the same Primitives right to
offer you an end-to-end backup manage
solution let's hear from a customer who
actually has done this in practice right
so
um
Francisco is the CTO of latam Airlines
right one of the largest Airlines in in
the latim domain and they have been he's
one of those Visionary leaders who took
a big bet on cloud a while back and they
are almost done if not already done in
migrating all the data centers off into
a cloud platform right and they took a
book back with us early on so without a
due let's roll the video you can see
hear from him himself
can we play the first video please
yeah oh sorry can you hear the cue the
sound if possible Lata Maryland is the
leading airline in South America with a
five-star Global rating an early this
year we achieved to become a 100 percent
cloud Airline by closing all of our data
center and moving all of our warlocks to
gcp
the criticality of our operation and the
sensitivity of our data make it very
important to have a solid backup
strategy
easy bdr is our trusted backup solution
for our gcp workloads gcbdr help us meet
compliance requirements and satisfied
regulatory Theory obligation for data
protection
we protect a broad portfolio of
overloads more than 1 000 production
warlock with those and of components
running in four regions
the ability to Define and enforce
complex policy for frequency retention
and expiration of backups and the
flexibility to apply different policies
based on criticality of the warlocks
help us achieve compliance across worlds
another relevant aspect using gcddr is
the ability to consistently manage
backups for multiple gcp workloads for a
single pane of glass
be it our Oracle database learn where
instances or our GCE VMS and Cloud SQL
instances we can manage Backup using the
single product
the fact that the service is an integral
part of the gcp platform makes it very
easy to operate by governing access and
monitoring backups operation via the
cloud monitoring services
last but not least working with gcp and
incorporating gcvdr backups as part of
our Cloud adoption has been a true
partnership
there is a great responsiveness to our
needs and support always is available
we value our partnership and will
continue to deploy additional workloads
leveraging gcbdr backups
thank you Francisco
so the one thing I want to share now is
that we really believe that today's
ransomware threats makes your backup
systems whatever it is a key part of
your security posture right security is
backup and backup is security
so when you're actually already in your
attack unfortunately it's a little too
late so I'd encourage you all to take
backups if you don't want to use Google
Cloud backup and Dr that's fine
definitely back up your data right today
the threat of ransomware is is
exceptionally high and I'll actually
share a story of how it happened with
one of our customers right
the next thing I want you to think about
is this framework so there's a really
good framework by nist which is an
organization in the US which has
actually put out a framework on how you
should think about your cyber resilience
posture right and there are two things I
want to highlight in this Google has a
lot of products that cover many many
aspects of this not the least of which
is mandiant another services company
that Google has
think about how you want to protect your
workloads and think about how you want
to recover your workloads that is where
Google Cloud backup and Dr and all the
backup capabilities that we have
invested in fit into your overall cyber
resilience posture okay
so now let me walk you through
a Cyber attack that happened right so
this was a customer they have about 30
plus factories in many locations each of
them actually had about a three or four
node VMware cluster they had a central
headquarter location which was a
slightly larger VMware cluster they had
about 900 VMS spread out across these 30
plus Geographic locations okay and they
were actually backing up and sending
they had a local copy for quick recovery
but they're sending their data back up
into gcp for protection
and then they were hit by a very
sophisticated attack some of you may
have heard of that attack Vector it's
called black cat slash Alpha V right now
this is a highly sophisticated attack
Vector that actually originates in being
able to use Active Directory Group
Policy objects to then distribute
payloads into various elements of your
environment and then from there they
basically go in
your data right and then the surface a
threat to you and say look if you need
your data back I'm gonna you're gonna
have to pay me some money to actually uh
you know get me to decrypt the data or
they also have a threat of being able to
release that data to the public domain
so this customer
you know unfortunately didn't have a
very sophisticated xdr system right so
they were not able to detect the attack
very quickly but as soon as it was
detected
you know the good thing they were able
to do
was to very quickly because their
on-prem environments were highly suspect
at this point of time by virtue of the
fact that we had backups in gcp we have
a Google Cloud VMware engines service
we've been able to very quickly bring
those backups back into gcp very quickly
right within days we were able to bring
out all those 900 VMS right and the
customer was back and operational and
then
okay I'm sorry I didn't want to talk to
you but so
um
get operational
and so that's something that was a
really benefit that they saw out of this
while they went and cleaned up their
on-premises environment so here you know
the act of being able to air gap a
logically air gap and keep their backups
in a separate location was highly
beneficial because they didn't weren't
impacted by the you know the the the
dangers of the ransomware encrypting
their backups themselves so that was a
hugely valuable proposition not the
least of which was to mention the GCV
itself offers some very sophisticated
networking capabilities which allowed
them to firewall plants and they brought
them back up so they were able to
actually utilize that isolation they
were able to use hcx Network extensions
to make sure that they were able to span
their networks so there were some really
cool things that they were able to do in
the context of responding to an attack
like this okay
so now that we've done this what I'd
like to do is to bring on Radha
chandrashekhar mathur and she'll walk
you through some more details of the
actual product that actually help this
kind of a recovery rather thank you
hello everyone
um I'm very excited to show you the
technology that makes cyber recovery
from backups possible
let us begin I think we want to bring
our demo video on
in this demo I'm going to show you how
to backup on-premises VMware workloads
and recover them in a logically
air-gapped environment in Google Cloud
VMware engine
to support this use case a backup
appliance which is the data mover
component of the backup and Dr service
is deployed on premises along with the
workloads that need to be backed up
the other component is the Management
console which is what we're looking at
this serves as the management plane for
multiple such backup appliances and this
is where backups are configured the
first step is to create a backup plan
let us go look at an existing backup
plan which has policies for scheduling
retention and storage the first rule in
this backup plan is for snapshots which
are stored on premises in a storage pool
and here the frequency is every four
hours and retention seven days the
second rule is for cloud backups these
are stored in a Google Cloud Storage
based onward pool in the cloud and
because they are intended for long-term
retention the you know retention is set
to 90 days once a backup plan with such
rules is defined the next step is to
apply them to the workloads we do that
in the backup and recover section here
we see the list of compute environments
and database applications that can be
backed up using Google Cloud backup and
Dr service
backup ndr agents are used to back up
this wide range of databases that are
displayed here
today's scenario doesn't employ an agent
clicking on VMware starts the process of
discovering a VMware environment we gave
we Center information selected the ESX
cluster then we get the list of VMS
select and group them and apply the
backup plan
this completes the process of
configuring backup for on-premises
VMware workloads
all the selected workloads are now
protected
ongoing backup operations are monitored
using the backup ndr dashboard this
provides information such as job status
protection status alerts events as well
as storage information across all
protected workloads
Cloud backups provide a great safety net
from ransomware
Backup ndr Service enables recovering
from these Cloud backups right in the
cloud as Vijay described using Google
Cloud VMware engine let's see how that
works the first step is to deploy a new
backup appliance which is deployed in
the cloud
because backups were stored in a Google
Cloud Storage based onward pool the new
backup Appliance can use the on-wall
pool which is in cloud and discover the
VMS and all the backups that were
created
we can see here
how a new backup Appliance has
discovered the VMS therefore protected
and their backups
to initiate recovery we select a
workload
and the next step is to select the
backup or recovery point from a catalog
of backups I'm gonna wait till we bring
up the catalog
here we can see both on-premises uh
snapshots that were created as well as
all the cloud backups for this workload
we can jump to a pretty previous point
in time and after selecting the recovery
point the next step is to provide the
gcve environment information where we
want this VM to be recovered
a recovery job gets initiated the job
monitor shows us its status and once
this job is complete a vsphere client
can be used to point to the vcenter
which is in Google Cloud VMware engine
and we can see that the workload we
recovered has become available here for
use this is how Google Cloud backup and
Dr service enables recovery of
on-premises VMware workloads in the
cloud using the logically air-gapped
gcve environment that
thank you so much for showing us this
demo what about what are we doing next
in this space
to share
excuse me can we switch back to the
slides
I'm excited to share how we are taking
this up a notch we saw how to recover
from cyber attacks now we are enabling
the ability to do early detection and
proactive prevention of attacks Google
Cloud backup ndr is integrating with
Google Cloud security Command Center
destructive actions from the backup
system such as deletion of backups
removal of workloads from protection
will be propagated to the security
Command Center
security Command Center or SCC will not
only provide alerts
based on that event but it will also
enable correlation of these events with
other actions such as security breaches
that's pretty cool so let's show you
another demo on how we do this in the
context of gke we're running a little
bit short of time so could we just move
forward a little bit Cara that would be
very helpful for us
we'll see how to protect for gke
workloads and
then we will see how to use backup World
functionality to safeguard these backups
from ransomware
so we're going to move a little forward
we're skipping over the part where we
apply a backup plan to workloads but we
look at an existing backup plan and
start from there
we're looking at the backup for gke
interface it's a part of the kubernetes
engine section of the Google Cloud
console
is there a network issue but get into
the video you think
there are 20 000 of you trying to access
the network what backup network will
survive that you tell me that
all right I think it seems it seems to
be we seem to be having some trouble
with the video let's see let Kara could
you try one more try if not then I'll
walk you through this demo in in uh in
the context of the talk track that I
have for this
all right that's fine let's go on to the
slides I'll walk you through thank you
so much rather really appreciate it all
right all right so um unfortunately we
couldn't show you the demo but what I'd
like to show you is is the following
right so what is backup for gke right we
recognize that you know clearly as the
devops movement took uh sort of move to
sort of took to ground a lot of
customers are coming to Google the home
of kubernetes and adopting gke right but
we needed a way for those customers to
also protect their workloads right and
what I mean by protect their workloads
actually spans multiple things in the
context of gke first and foremost is
when you're deploying clusters in gke
you want to make sure that your cluster
configuration is backed up right so we
offer an ability for you to say look I
don't want to worry about data because
my state is sitting in some external
data store like a cloud SQL alloy DB GCS
whatever it is I just want to make sure
that the configuration of my kubernetes
clusters is backed up right so we offer
that ability right we call them
stateless clusters we can back it up you
can restore it you can restore it
whether you're doing it for you know
using it get Ops operation you're doing
CI CD and want to be able to you know
recover roll back to a different cluster
State no problem at all another place we
people see using this is for migration
of clusters from one region to another
the next place is obviously in case you
want to actually do have state inside
containers right so if you've got
persistent disks that are plumbed into
your kubernetes clusters and you've got
pods where you want to be able to back
up these things we've got uh a a an
ability for you to be able to schedule
backups for kubernetes using both
stateless and stateful clusters right so
we'll be able to back up the disk
we also offer a hook so if you've got
you know some sophisticated acquires in
algorithm that you want to run on your
workload you know tickle this ping this
and then I'll acquire the database then
take the snapshot we've got a sidecar
architecture which allows you to run
your code which acquires is the workload
that's running inside the container
before you actually take snapshot of the
disk right and then obviously we we
enable recovery of that within gke as
well right the other thing I'd like you
to focus on is actually you know the the
the UI itself so this is the the UI of
gke right and if you actually go see
right here this is backup that's
embedded right into the user experience
for gke so if you've got a devops team
or developers who are actually working
through the UI or through terraform or
through gcloud they can get a seamless
experience where you can Define the
policy and then the developers can
basically just enable the policy and you
can make sure that you know their
workloads are backed up so you as backup
administrators are not worried about my
god did my kubernetes platform owners
did they actually back up the Clusters
or not right set the policy and it's in
their flow in their tooling right with
there they are right so that's an
opportunity of
how do you try to integrate with the
workloads in fact you'll see us do more
of this with backup and Dr we'll
integrate into GCE we'll integrate into
Cloud SQL our goal really is to be
fundamental to the workload itself is
how you'll be able to backup makes sense
all right so I think I've given you
enough office now so what the demo was
really going to show you was this thing
in action and more importantly it was
going to show you that backup for gke
already has the ability to have
immutable and indelible backups right
that means you can put the backup into a
snapshot and say I've locked the key I
don't want anybody to delete this backup
for the next 30 days and we'll enforce
that retention period for you right come
what may it's protected from any super
user nobody can go and delete that basic
backup so that's the capability that's
already available for you to use in the
context of gke what I'd like to do now
is to invite
he is
um you know as as rather uh you know
Laura already introduced him he's from
cyber Haven so go ahead please Rado
thank you so uh I'd like to first
introduce the company a product a bit
and then we'll talk a bit about how we
use Google backup
we're a cyber security company we're a
startup a relatively Midway in the
journey where past series big and close
to CDC
and our product protects Enterprise data
and the way it does that is by mapping
out all of the movement of the data
within various locations in the company
and why that's helpful is that by doing
this we can protect data based on
lineage so in the context of DLP I know
that there's some security people in the
audience rather than saying I want to
prevent data containing free letters
four digits and a DOT from going to chat
applications we can say I don't want my
data from the legal folder in Google
Drive going to chat that's much easier
much more intuitive as well as much more
powerful
how that translates to the technical
side is we are essentially manipulating
a very large graph very large mini
meaning literally trillions of nodes and
on this graph we are constantly doing
scans aggregations and modifications it
actually modifies thousands of times per
second that's a very tough problem and
actually there isn't we didn't find a
good way to just take an out of the box
solution to do all of this data
processing for us so we built our own
system on top of a bunch of different
Services they are all Google services
like bigquery Pub sub bigtable
and then we have our own code acting
basically as the glue putting all of
this data together to form this complex
graph model
and this is where uh Google backup for
GK really comes in it makes all of our
work much easier
application to utilize core gcp services
like bigtable and others and you got a
tremendous amount of benefit for that
but tell us a little more about what
backup for gke gave you and how did it
help you improve your posture
all right so uh I guess the short story
what I like about backup.dk is that it
just works it goes very deep in gke we
are using a lot of Google services so it
just covers everything out of the box it
has deep integration with all of the
different resources that we have
it covers everything as the application
evolves we are still in the early stage
of our journey so the application
evolves very rapidly and that means that
we are adding new services and might
forget to add backups for that
with Google backup for gke we know that
we don't have to have developers or we
don't have to have processes to make
sure that we don't forget to config
backups or something
backup 4gk does that does that for us
that's really fantastic Radu thank you
so much for being a great advocate for
backup for gke but not only that being a
great partner through the cycle of as
we've developed this I'm going to put
you a little bit on the spot and ask you
in front of all of these people what is
the next thing you would like us to do
in backup for gke
what I think would make a lot of sense
is to have backup evolve from uh purely
doing backups to being more of a
coordination service for snapshots we
have a bunch of different Services
running in different projects in Google
and managing the backups around among
all of these different projects is quite
complex so what I really like from
backup for GK is to become a let's say a
coordination module for the disability
platform mechanism where we can have a
consistent snapshot across all of these
Services done at the same at a single
point in time
that's fantastic thank you so much
radufort here and he's going to be
around here at the end of the session so
please catch him and he'll be able to
answer questions for you thank you so
much really appreciate it all right so I
think first of all I apologize for the
video not playing up for the for the
backup
session uh I will uh point out one more
thing we will make sure that the demo is
recorded and available to you so the
recording of this session will have a
link to the video that you can play for
the backup for GK dma as well right so
you've seen variants of this slide
already the key takeaway I want all of
you to member is that local cloud has
invested deeply in making sure you have
backup functionality to protect against
ransomware at every layer of the stack
me as the owner of the backup and Dr
product utilize the same apis that you
have if you want to directly go to the
cloud SQL API the by bigquery API the
persistent disk API it's all in your
hands if you want to do it but then
we've taken the pain to make sure that
we can give you a finished managed
end-to-end Service as well which will
give you things like indelible and
immutable backups sophisticated
scheduling integration with Cloud
monitoring so you can get all the
capabilities that you're used to in a
robust
backup solution that gives you reporting
monitoring and all of these
functionalities right
and then the last thing I want you to
remember is because we are deeply
integrated into Google it greatly
simplifies the operational model that
you all have to learn you don't have to
relearn some other thing it's all Google
we use the same rbac model the same IM
model so it helps you
um you know one of the things that you
you'll hear quite often from the
security Community is secure by default
right and we take a lot of pride in
making sure that when we deploy and
manage your backups we are secure by
default so you get all the benefit of
the learning that we as a backup and Dr
team have accrued over petabytes of data
that we back up which we share back into
the product to make sure that the
product and captures all those best
practices for you right so it's
available now for all of you to use in
the context of gke deeply integrated
Google Cloud backup and Dr is available
for you as well so thank you so much I
want to leave some time for for
questions so that brings me to the end
of my my talk track so happy to take and
answer any questions that you have
foreign